hi everybody i hope we're all doing well
um
some of my favorite moments in every
stormlight book so far
happens within the last hundred pages uh
that's not to say there aren't great
moments
in the rest of the book you go in
knowing
okay there's going to be a lot of build
up and things are going to progress to a
point where it's just so much happening
all at once
pacing in fantasy books in general
there are different expectations you
know you don't go into epic fantasy
expecting thriller
pace or you know a why a romance
expecting
a fantasy pace you know going into a
fantasy book there's going to be
likely many characters multiple points
of view traditional fantasy
with a huge emphasis on world building
you know you don't really go into
reading a fantasy book
unless you enjoy world building on some
level and
epic fantasy when you are consciously
making huge
gigantic books which sanderson is doing
with the stormlight archive that changes
things too
these conceptions about pacing and
fantasy
make it really interesting and make it
an interesting problem for
for writers to figure out how to address
and keep the story moving and keep a
sense of progression while also
delivering on all of this extra stuff
and i think that generally sanderson is
excellent at doing this
and i think a perfect comparison that
can be made
is with words of radiance and
oathbringer
so i think that in general you could
talk about pacing on
a small scale and pacing on a very large
scale
sanderson writes chapters in the
stormlight archive that are
short stories almost and you see that in
the in the interlude chapters
each chapter often feels like a short
story in itself
often they're self-contained often
they're uh sometimes a chapter is meant
just to explore the world
we want to see some kind of character
interaction some kind of
goal achieved or twist and i think
that's done
really well however it doesn't feel like
there's a lot of continuity from chapter
chat to chapter
and this is really prevalent in
oathbringer especially when the point of
view
characters start to expand and expand
and expand and i personally
felt like i could read a chapter one
chapter of oathbringer and go
i'm good for the day you know that had a
nice little arc
in that chapter more of a leisurely pace
you know you
want to take your time exploring this
book that's fine but it
becomes hard when the whole macro level
plot doesn't get resolved until the last
couple of chapters
and especially when you've become used
to that formula in the first two books
you know like okay there's going to be a
lot of
treading water part of my problem with
oathbringer is that i was really hyper
conscious of it
i i could feel like okay this is gonna
be delayed
until the very end and then this this
thread of
of plot is not going to coincide with
this thread of plot
until the very end and it started to
feel a little bit
more convenient in words of radiance
there's the ticking
clock so the final part i want to
discuss is divisions
of progress just so that for the sake of
getting into more detail into this i'm
going to be talking about spoilers until
this time so if you don't want to hear
spoilers just jump to
for for oathbringer just jump to this
time and um
there you go you know trying to liberate
the town of kolinar
this whole sequence is the is so
interesting to me because i feel like
building up to it i was so excited i was
like man this is going to be great we
have all of our characters
that we love together you know there's
going to be some interesting tension
between shalon and khalid and
adeline and and elokar you know is
trying to redeem himself
but we're totally left out of the loop
and then when we get there you know it
kind of reminds me of like the build up
to a great
to like an action movie or um in aliens
the the military is coming back and
ripley's with them and they know
something bad is going on on the planet
you know they don't know exactly what it
is yet
but they know something's bad it felt
like as soon as they got to culinary
it became describing you know exactly
how this town is working
all of this stuff and as soon as the
characters get there seemed like they
all split off
they kind of had their own little side
quests as soon as they got there and
especially when it felt like okay our
characters have kind of been separate
from each other now this is the moment
when they can be together
progress is all divided into little
things and they're all separated
we have this goal but suddenly we have
these little side stories
that have gotten in the way and
distracted us well another example is
shadesmar which happens right after the
culinary stuff there's a lot of focus on
just describing this whole new world
and figuring out how it works which can
be really fun but
when story threads are unresolved when
it feels like all of the conflict and
tension that happened in culinary just
put on pause
and we're just like going what's what's
going on we don't know we're left in the
dark
it feels frustrating in some ways it was
just
it was a massive book with three
different books inside of it or four
different books inside of it and that's
my problem
somewhat with oathbringer however it's
hard to even blame it because
i feel like that's like a herculean task
i think pacing in novels is one of the
most like under discussed
topics the pacing of a scene the pacing
of a paragraph of a sentence you know
is just so hard sometimes to
sense and hear and and get a grip on
sometimes
the pacing of a chapter might be great
which i feel like sanderson's
chapter pacing is wonderful and he has
wonderful little arcs within each
chapter and section but brought all
together
some things were way over developed and
over discussed and some things were
really underdeveloped you know it's a
topic i wanted to talk about because
i haven't talked a lot about oathbringer
it's one of those books that i
really i enjoyed reading but i also felt
a little weird about it anyways that's
what i have to say about it i hope uh
any of this is uh interesting
thank you for watching and if you if you
want to hear any of my more
other opinions you know i have them so
thanks for watching by the way i have a
patreon now so that's
um that's around you want to support the
channel that that's uh
hugely appreciated and uh yeah anyways
thank you for watching
and have a good one